most people generally don't have a very
positive opinion of Amazon the business
they may love the service and
convenience that Amazon offers but more
times than not people aren't exactly
fans of Jeff Bezos or how Amazon is run
the media often portrays Jeff Bezos as
someone who makes tens of billions while
his everyday employees break their backs
for minimum wage there is some a truth
to this narrative given that Jeff Bezos
does often make tens of billions every
year and his employees do have terrible
working conditions their drivers are
Infamous for peeing in bottles and their
warehouse workers are often treated like
disposable robots want a Nuance that's
rarely talked about though is the fact
that Amazon does not actually make any
money and this has been the case for
much of their entire history a few years
ago they were able to achieve
sustainable profitability with their
retail business for the first time but
with inflation skyrocketing the retail
business has fallen back into the red by
quite an amount in the first six months
of 2022 Amazon was able to achieve an
impressive
143.6 billion dollars worth of sales in
North America but to achieve this number
they had to spend
145.8 billion dollars meaning that they
lost 2.2 billion dollars outside North
America Amazon was able to achieve net
sales of 55.8 billion dollars but it
cost them 58.8 billion dollars to
fulfill these orders meaning that they
lost 3 billion dollars internationally
while Amazon's Executives like to play
it calm when they talk to the media or
shareholders there is some evidence that
they're actually scrambling internally
likely the best example of this is all
the rumors that they're gonna hold the
second prime day in October apparently
they're not gonna call it Prime day
though instead they're gonna call it
Prime Early Access sales whatever they
call it though it this is clearly a move
to capitalize on the holiday season and
a bolster the their quarterly report but
why is Amazon's retail business losing
money in the first place and can the
retail business ever become sustainably
profitable
fortunately for us Amazon has been a
public company for a long time meaning
that all of their financials for the
past 25 years are all public by far the
largest category in which Amazon spends
money is actually acquiring the products
that they sell if it's an Amazon branded
product like a Kindle or an Alexa
speaker this consists of directly paying
suppliers for the product and shipping
it to their warehouses if it's a private
label brand or a third-party seller
however this is the portion of the
revenue that Amazon has to share with
these parties in the first six months of
2022 this number came out to being a
132.9 billion dollars This Is Not a Bad
Thing given that this is where you want
Amazon to spend money you want them to
spend money on acquiring good quality
products and it by the looks of it
they're spending over half of their
revenue on acquiring products but this
is actually super misleading you see the
variance and how much Amazon has to
share with their sellers is insane when
it comes to large Brands like apple
Amazon has to hand over well above 90
percent of the revenue to Apple but when
it comes to FBA sellers however this
number is usually closer to 20 to 30
percent if that and this is what leads
to the vast discrepancy and quality
across Amazon anyway Amazon's second
most expensive category is of course
fulfillment shipping any product to any
household in America within 48 hours if
not 24 hours is by no means a cheap
Endeavor it takes hundreds of thousands
of warehouse workers at delivery drivers
Pilots trucks planes warehouses boxes
packaging materials and who knows what
else within the first half of 2022
fulfillment cost Amazon 40.6 billion
dollars which works out to a little more
than a sixth of the revenue during the
same time period this means that on
average whenever you buy something on
Amazon roughly 1 6 of your purchase
price literally goes towards just
getting it to you speak about expensive
shipping moving on we have the
technology and the content category
story this includes all of the licensing
fees that Amazon has to pay for Prime
movies and music this also includes
development and maintenance expenses for
things like Alexa and a twitch within
the first two quarters of 2022 these
added up to 32.9 billion dollars and
that brings us into our final major
expense which is sales and marketing
Amazon is actually rather conservative
when it comes to running ads well
technically this category did add up to
being 18.4 billion dollars but in
comparison to their net sales this is
not even 10 there are a few other
categories that Amazon spends money in
like General and administrative and
miscellaneous expenses but these aren't
particularly notable General and
administrative came out to 5.5 billion
dollars while miscellaneous expenses
came out to 339 million dollars and it's
really just the first four categories
that really weigh down Amazon's bottom
line by the time they're done paying for
those categories they either have little
money left or they're in the red
foreign
if Amazon's retail business is at best a
low margin business how did Amazon
become a trillion dollar company in the
first place well this is not a new
question by any means in fact Jeff Bezos
and his executive team were thinking
about this not five or ten years ago but
22 years ago this is when the.com crash
unfolded it which essentially wiped out
Amazon stock Amazon stock would crash 95
percent but Amazon was actually one of
the lucky survivors the vast majority of
internet companies straight up went to
bankrupt and shut down but while Amazon
survived this bloodbath it was clear to
Jeff Bezos that they couldn't just keep
betting on retail in if they truly
wanted to become a leader in retail he
knew that they had to spend a decade
building up Logistics fulfillment and
product diversity and all of that would
probably leave the business in the red
in the 1990s Jeff was able to use the
hype surrounding internet companies to
raise extraordinary amounts of money to
keep the money pit afloat but with
the.com crash that was clearly no longer
viable so the executive started
brainstorming about how they could
sustain it Amazon's retail business they
didn't want to spend a lot of effort
entering a completely different industry
or inventing something new because that
would just take away from their retail
business so they looked for ways in
which they could leverage what they
already had one of their first ideas was
to create a service called merchant.com
that could help people create online
stores Amazon already had a lot of
experience building an e-commerce
business so they figured they'd be
pretty good at helping others do the
same thing and given their reputation
within e-commerce they were actually
able to track some high quality clients
like Target but very quickly they
realized that offering the service was
more of a full-time gig rather than a
side gig so they shut down merchant.com
pretty quickly ironically Shopify has
since started a full-on business around
it just this and at the peak they were
worth over 200 billion dollars but
anyway going back to the struggling
Amazon they had to find new options
leasing out their expertise that wasn't
quite working so they started thinking
about what else they could lease out
they could lease out their fulfillment
service and this is something that they
would eventually do but as a startup
this was too big of an undertaking
something that was easy to lease out
though was their computer infrastructure
they had plenty of servers databases and
networks what if they just leased these
out and that right there marked the
beginning of Amazon web services or AWS
most people have never heard of AWS and
will probably never buy an AWS offering
but this is the secret that has been
keeping Amazon alive
foreign
's retail margins aren't that impressive
the same cannot be said about their
Cloud business in terms of Revenue AWS
doesn't pull in all that much in
comparison to Amazon's total revenue in
the first six months of 2022 AWS pulled
in 38.1 billion dollars which works out
to roughly 1 6 of Amazon's total revenue
but AWS carries a monstrous operating
margin of 32 percent which leaves them
with an operating income of 12.2 billion
dollars now compared to Amazon's total
revenue this is still not that much but
it has been enough to build out their
retail business for the past 16 years we
thought AWS Amazon would have lost about
5.2 billion dollars from the retail
business within the first half of this
year but with AWS Amazon ended up
profiting just under 7 billion dollars
now of course that's just operating
income after Amazon wrote off 15 zillion
dollars with the losses from rivian and
other Investments they were back in the
red within that loss of 5.8 billion
dollars also we should mention that
that's what the two billion tax rebate
without this rebate Amazon would have
lost 7.9 billion dollars and if it
weren't for AWS that loss would have
jumped up to over 20 billion dollars
ironically that's about how much Walmart
profited it in the most recent 12-month
period so clearly Amazon's retail
business and Northern Investments are
performing especially well right now but
can Amazon turn things around well it
depends on how you define it turn things
around if you define it as simply can
Amazon's retail business become
profitable again then the answer is
absolutely as Amazon hacks Prime
membership fees and FBI seller fees
they're essentially passing on inflation
to customers and sellers and it's just a
matter of time until they're able to
squeeze back into the green but if we
Define turn things around as becoming
truly profitable then things aren't so
clear margins across the retail industry
are generally just not that great
Walmart for example has a dominated
North American retail for decades but
even Walmart is only able to achieve a
2.5 net margin even at their Peak they
weren't able to cross a four percent net
margin a similar Trend can be seen with
Target as well Target was able to reach
a peak margin of six and a half percent
during the pandemic but that's already
coming back down to their average of
four percent while Amazon does not have
to pay for stores like these guys Amazon
ends up spending all that money on Fast
home shipping so it really doesn't make
a difference while I don't think
Amazon's retail business will
perpetually lose money forever I also
have a tough time ever seeing them cross
a 10 net margin so we'll probably never
see Amazon's retail business reach the
insane 20 30 40 margins of their Fang
peers but that's just the reality of the
industry that they're in
foreign
doesn't actually make as much money as
you might think but why does that even
matter well the reason that might matter
is because of Amazon stock Amazon stock
has historically always traded at a high
p e ratio which is the ratio between a
company's earnings and their market cap
mature companies that generally trade
for a PE ratio of 10 but Amazon is
trading for a PE ratio of almost 110.
historically this was tolerated because
Amazon was growing so fast I mean they
have yet to have it year-over-year
decline in Revenue but at the same time
it's also clear that they're starting to
level out this isn't a bad thing it's
actually just a natural but it also
raises a lot of red flags as to whether
Amazon should have such a high PE ratio
anymore investors are starting to become
wary and this is already evident in the
charts Amazon was the only Fan company
whose stock didn't go vertical during
2020 and depend 2021 their stock has
basically been going sideways for over
four years now for perspective Apple
stock is up 175 since 2018. even after
accounting for the recent sell-off so
there's no doubt that Amazon stock has
stalled the real question is whether
this is simply a pit stop or a sign of
something much more bearish are you a
fan of Amazon the business comment that
down below also drop a like if you wish
that this bear Market would just be over
already and of course consider checking
out our Discord Community to suggest
future video ideas and to consider
subscribing to see more questions all
you've answered but until then I'm Hari
Nazi guys on the next one
foreign